yeah the existence of nuclear weapons
pandemics
all kinds of threats yeah should uh
should kind of um give us some
motivation
I mean civilization could get
um
could die with a bang or a whimper
you know if it's uh if it dies a
demographic collapse then it's more of a
whimper obviously but and if it's world
war three it's more of a bang but but
these are all risks
um I mean it's important to think of
these things and just you know things
things like probabilities not
certainties
um there's a certain probability that
something bad will happen on earth like
I think most likely the future will be
good
um but there's like let's say for August
sake
um a one percent chance per Century of
of a civilization ending event like that
was Stephen Hawking's estimate
um
I think he's he might be right about
that so
then
uh
you know we should basically think of
this like being a multi-planet species
just like taking out insurance for life
itself like life insurance for life
um wow so it's turned into an
infomercial real quick life insurance
for Life yes
um and you know we can bring the the
creatures from you know plants and
animals from Earth to Mars and breathe
life into the planet
um
and and have a second planet with with
life
um that would be great um they can't
bring themselves there you know so if we
don't bring them to Mars then they will
just for sure all die when the sun
expands anyway and then that'll be it